[Musica]
buongiorno oggi vorrei parlarvi di
alcuni strumenti che molti di noi
utilizzano quotidianamente i social
media
i dati dell'agenzia we are social 2021
ci dicono che i social vengono sempre
più utilizzati dalle persone con alcuni
social che sono rimasti dominanti nel
tempo come facebook e instagram e altri
come tik tok che stanno prendendo piede
soprattutto nei giovani
nell'ultimo periodo il fascia sono
utilizzate effettivamente da persone di
diverse fasce di età a volte anche un po
sotto l'età consentita per svolgere
diverse funzioni per una durata di circa
due ore al giorno
in realtà potremmo pensare che i social
ci aiutino e ci servono soprattutto per
sviluppare e mantenere relazioni ma il
discorso è un po più complesso
personalmente ho cominciato a studiare
le caratteristiche individuali implicate
nell'utilizzo dei social circa 20 anni
fa nella mia tesi di laurea in
psicologia in particolare quel filone di
studi ha dato luogo poi è un area che
effettivamente ha permesso di
riscontrare come le persone facciano un
uso differenziato dei social anche a
secondo di alcune caratteristiche
individuali ad esempio le persone
estroverse che sono più attive che sono
più dinamiche che hanno più contatti
sono effettivamente anche più attivi sui
social e hanno più contatti online le
persone amicali invece che sono persone
che sono più orientate al supporto
all'ascolto alla qualità delle relazioni
mettono in atto dei comportamenti
effettivamente diversi online
quindi se ci chiedessimo mai social
allora fanno bene o fanno male perché i
social possono costituire un rischio per
il benessere delle persone
ecco che allora per rispondere a questa
domanda abbiamo bisogno di comprendere
quali sono i meccanismi psicologici che
sono attivati dall uso di queste
piattaforme che offrono caratteristiche
differenziate tra questi meccanismi
uno è quello appunto della mancanza di
un segnale di fine nei comportamenti e
di questo ci rendiamo conto soprattutto
quando facciamo un utilizzo passivo
quando scrolliamo i profili quando
guardiamo i post degli altri le immagini
video e ci rendiamo conto che non
abbiamo dei segnali che ci aiutano a
capire quando quel comportamento deve
terminare mentre quando per esempio
incontriamo le persone faccia a faccia
abbiamo un inizio una durata di un
incontro una fine che ci aiuta appunto a
completare la nostra azione
ecco la mancanza di questi segnali di
fine ci porta un po un comportamento
difficile da regolare che ci richiede
più responsabilità nel definire dei
momenti di stop e questo fenomeno ha
portato alcuni autori come alter ad
esempio parlare proprio di screen
irresistibili come a dire che i social
sono un po delle calamite che ci
attraggono e da qui facciamo fatica a
staccarci oltretutto quando incontriamo
le persone faccia a faccia in realtà noi
li guardiamo negli occhi guardiamo la
loro mimica facciale guardiamo la loro
gestualità e cerchiamo di capire le
emozioni che provano mentre stanno
parlando con noi mentre ci stanno
ascoltando quindi cerchiamo di
comprendere le loro reazioni ai nostri
comportamenti e ciò che diciamo
ecco questo nei social non avviene
perché online
i segnali metà comunicativi non sono
presenti e questo porta alcune persone a
mettere in atto dei comportamenti più
aggressivi online ad esempio addirittura
a volte anche un po crudeli come se
l'altro non fosse presente pure l'altro
c'è e cioè come altri meccanismi
psicologici che vengono attivati fanno
riferimento ad esempio al bisogno di
ricevere conferme ha bisogno è la
possibilità di ricevere approvazione
quindi non soltanto approvazione per ciò
che si è spostato ma anche un po per ciò
che si è infatti provate a pensare
all'ultimo post che avete condiviso che
effettivamente vi permetteva un po di
condividere un vostro pensiero una
vostra esperienza non avete un po
sentito il desiderio di controllare
quanti lai che avete ricevuto quanti
commenti positivi avevate ricevuto
questo fenomeno è normale e gli studi
neuroscientifici ci dicono che i like
attivano il circuito della ricompensa
che lo stesso circuito che si attiva
quando ad esempio mangiamo un cibo buono
o quando utilizziamo alcune sostanze e
questo sistema della gratificazione ci
porta a mettere in atto in maniera
continuativa il comportamento proprio in
attesa di ricevere nuovi laiche di
ricevere nuove conferme e poi siamo
sinceri quante volte postiamo delle
immagini in cui non siamo venuti bene
o ci sentiamo di condividere
un'esperienza di fallimento
un'esperienza in cui non ci siamo
sentiti competenti probabilmente poche
questo meccanismo si chiama positivity
by us ed è il meccanismo per cui le
persone tendono a presentarsi in maniera
più desiderabile online a enfatizzare
degli aspetti migliorativi di sé con il
desiderio di attrarre socialmente gli
altri di stimolare la vicinanza
ecco questo processo se può essere
positivo in alcune situazioni di vita ad
esempio in adolescenza in cui è un po in
atto un esplorazione della propria
identità può essere però rischioso nel
momento in cui si prende davvero un po
una distanza da ciò che si è davvero e
gli studi ci dicono che la presentazione
on line autentica di semplice associata
al benessere e le persone che si
presentano autentica mente sono persone
che hanno una buona valutazione di sé le
persone che hanno già una rete sociale
positiva
oltretutto il bisogno di ricevere
conferme approvazione anche alla base di
altri tipi di comportamenti per esempio
può stare o condividere fec news non
tanto quindi focalizzandosi su ciò che
si ha da dire ma sul fatto che ciò che
si dice ciò che si condivide permette di
ricevere approvazione like divertimento
e addirittura porta alcuni giovani anche
giovani non vulnerabili dal punto di
vista della salute mentale a scegliere
di partecipare a delle social challenge
on line come black out challenge come la
blu e il proprio per il desiderio di
spingersi anche in situazioni che
possono essere rischiose che possono
essere pericolose pur di ricevere
approvazione da proprio dal proprio
gruppo sociale
i social però non ci offrono soltanto
rischi ma anche opportunità ad esempio
tutti nell'ultimo anno abbiamo potuto
constatare che i social ci hanno
permesso di mantenere le nostre
relazioni con amici con persone
significative con familiari anche
distanti o che comunque a causa del
distanziamento sociale non potevamo
incontrare quindi social hanno permesso
di superare un po la solitudine e
l'isolamento è però l'utilizzo dei
social attivo in cui le persone sono
portate ad attivare la cosiddetta set
disclosure cioè a narrare le proprie
esperienze
e a narrare le proprie emozioni che
stimola la vicinanza sociale e facilità
e supporta il benessere delle persone e
poi attraverso i soci alle persone
possono osservare attraverso le tracce
digitali lasciate dagli altri e
confrontarsi stimolare riflettere su ciò
che sono sui loro comportamenti sulle
loro risorse sulle loro competenze
ovviamente questo è un processo che si
attiva anche al di fuori dei social e
possono anche rincorrere i loro ideali
per esempio grazie a questa occasione è
nato fra gli sport user che è un
movimento che è nato in un contesto
isolato e che è diventato poi invece un
movimento globale di protesta che ha
avvicinato ragazzi di tutto il mondo per
protestare contro il riscaldamento
globale contro il cambiamento climatico
quindi attraverso i social le persone
possono anche partecipare attivamente
possono contribuire con il proprio
impegno civico possono essere testimoni
di ciò che osservano e di ciò che a
volte i media tradizionali
magari non manifestano e non condividono
quindi se proviamo a tornare alla
domanda iniziale i social fanno bene o
fanno male per rispondere a questa
domanda
dobbiamo considerare le diverse
traiettorie d'uso che le persone fanno e
quindi effettivamente riconoscere che
alcune persone sono più portate a
sfruttare le opportunità dei social e
altri invece cioè incorrere nei
potenziali rischi per comprendere le
traiettorie di utilizzo dei social
dobbiamo comprendere le motivazioni che
sono alla base dei diversi comportamenti
ad esempio le persone che utilizzano di
più per tirarsi su quando sono giù di
morale quando sono tristi quando sono
arrabbiati quando sono ansiosi oppure
guardano i profili dei loro colleghi per
confrontarsi per condividere opportunità
lavorative o invece per confrontarsi
effettivamente valutare quanto valgono e
quando guardiamo invece le immagini
postate da altri le facciamo per
osservare gli altri o per valutare il
nostro corpo
ecco che le motivazioni ci aiutano a
capire queste diverse traiettorie
in particolare la teoria
dell'autodeterminazione di ryan e 10 ci
dice che esistono tre bisogni nati
psicologici di base di competenza di
relazione e di autonomia cioè le persone
hanno il bisogno di sentirsi competenti
rispetto al loro ambiente sociale
rispetto all'oro ambienti di riferimento
quindi vedere che attraverso la pratica
era esercizio riescono sviluppare delle
abilità sentire di stare in relazione
positiva con altre persone quindi
facilitare il loro senso di appartenenza
sociale ma anche sentire di avere
autonomia e quindi sentirsi artefici un
po delle esperienze che decidono di
vivere e del loro destino
ecco che quando questi tre bisogni sono
soddisfatti le persone funzionano in
maniera adattiva si funzionano in
maniera ottimale e anche il loro
utilizzo dei social effettivamente
positivo invece quando questi meccanismi
quasi bisogni di base non sono
soddisfatti le persone mettono in atto
comportamenti anche disadattivi per
esempio questo ci aiuta a spiegare il
famoso fenomeno della fir missing out la
paura di restare fuori quel apprensione
che gli altri si stanno scambiando
qualcosa di divertente di sentirsi un po
esclusi dal proprio gruppo sociale che
porta anche un po compulsivamente a
controllare che cosa gli altri si stanno
dicendo online ecco la fyrom insegnata
abbiamo visto anche in alcune ricerche
che effettivamente è associata a un
mancato soddisfacimento di questi
bisogni e in particolare il bisogno di
relazione ecco che allora la situazione
rispetto all'utilizzo dei social
effettivamente complessa e forse per
comprenderla maggiormente dobbiamo fare
un po un passaggio indietro cioè
dobbiamo riflettere effettivamente su
che cosa significhi utilizzare
consapevolmente e con responsabilità ai
social
dobbiamo innanzitutto farci delle
domande
prima persona rispetto a come lo
utilizziamo rispetto a quali sono le
motivazioni che ci spingono utilizzarlo
in un certo modo e poi dobbiamo forse
attivare delle buone abitudini e quindi
pensare che ci sono anche dei momenti in
cui ci concentriamo su quello che stiamo
facendo
dedichiamo la nostra attenzione
all'altro se siamo con altre persone in
presenza e lasciamo i social sullo
sfondo e poi ricordarci che se siamo
adulti siamo dei modelli che i bambini e
gli adolescenti attraverso
l'osservazione dei modelli sono portati
a mettere in atto degli schemi
comportamentali simili e quindi a loro
volta a utilizzare in un certo modo per
esempio le tecnologie oi social e quando
la tecnologia non si mette in mezzo tra
noi e loro
abbiamo l'occasione di far sviluppare
maggiore consapevolezza emotiva maggiore
capacità di riconoscere le emozioni
dell'altro che è la base delle
competenze sociali che poi ci aiutano a
funzionare bene in tanti contesti di
vita e le emozioni viaggiano in line non
soltanto le emozioni negative come ad
esempio la rabbia che attiva dei
messaggi d'odio ma anche le emozioni
positive come la meraviglia come l'amore
come la compassione come la gratitudine
che abbiamo recentemente studiato che
può essere espressa può essere fruita
online attivo dei circoli viziosi e
attiva un contagio emotivo positivo
vorrei quindi concludere pensando agli
ultimi dati dei rapporti ocse pisa 2018
e gli stati ct cittadini 2019 che
effettivamente ci dicono che i giovani
ragazzi ragazze utilizzano sempre di più
le piattaforme social ma che questo non
va di pari passo con lo sviluppo di
alcune competenze e allora per favorire
invece il loro uso positivo loro uso
consapevole e responsabile
la possibilità di partecipare
attivamente dimostrando il loro impegno
civile partecipando alla vita
democratica
bisogna lavorare di più sulla educazione
positiva e media digitali lavorando sia
alle competenze digitali ma anche forse
su competenze che sono squisitamente
psicologiche